Trascrizione: Cecilia Negri
Revisore: Cuicani Ríos
[Musica]
[Applausi]
Che cos'è l'eccellenza?
È un traguardo o un percorso?
È qualcosa che appartiene a pochi,
o che tutti noi possiamo avere?
Esiste un'eccellenza diversa da quella
che abitualmente immaginiamo.
È un'eccellenza
che va oltre il traguardo,
e che appartiene a ciascuno di noi.
Perché è dentro di noi,
in modi e forme diverse.
E più la usiamo,
più si consolida e si espande.
E se ne sta lì, seduta in noi,
ad aspettare di essere vissuta
e sperimentata.
Che cos'è?
È la capacità di mettersi
in contatto con noi stessi
e di riconoscere tutto ciò
che è positivo dentro di noi,
le nostre qualità, le aspirazioni,
le capacità di azione,
le nostre potenzialità;
e più abbracciamo
questa eccellenza,
più liberiamo
la nostra capacità di esistere.
Ed è una meraviglia.
Quando ero antropologa,
ho lavorato e vissuto
in molti paesi,
e ho interagito
con persone di diverso genere.
Ho affrontato situazioni difficili
e, come molti di noi, me la sono cavata.
Ci sono state, però, delle volte,
in cui mi sono stupita
delle incredbili soluzioni
che il mio corpo, la mia mente,
avevano escogitato
per salvare me stessa
e per aiutare gli altri.
Ed è stato in quei momenti
che stare in ascolto, fidarmi
e mettermi in contatto
con ciò che vivevo di positivo in me,
mi ha permesso di scoprire
le risorse e le capacità
che avevo dentro.
È stato in quei momenti
che io ho capito
che noi siamo più di quello che crediamo.
Nel Gennaio del 1998,
tre milioni di persone nel sud del Québec
vivono un'esperienza drammatica.
Io sono una di loro.
Per sei giorni una tempesta di ghiaccio
si abbatte sull'area,
lasciandoci in completo black out,
senza riscaldamento né elettricità,
a temperature sotto zero.
Sotto il peso del ghiaccio,
chilometri di tralicci dell'alta tensione
crollano a terra.
Anche gli alberi crollano.
Crollano sulle case, nelle strade,
sulle macchine.
Come nei film dell'Apocalisse,
ci troviamo per strada
con molti altri.
Ricordo camminare nelle strade, al buio,
con una torcia.
Il cielo è così pesante
che sembra caderci addosso.
Ricordo lo scricchiolio
macabro degli alberi
che stanno per cadere,
e sono terrorizzata,
non riesco a vedere dove sono,
sento la gente urlare,
e provo un inconsolabile
bisogno di protezione.
I giorni che passano
sono giorni di pura sopravvivenza.
Quando il black out finisce,
la vita riprende, poco a poco.
Ma non per me.
Rimango con un profondo
senso di desolazione
e di totale aridità.
E mi chiudo sempre di più.
Per giorni e giorni,
mi sveglio alla mattina
cercando un motivo, una ragione
per andare avanti.
E mi dico, ma come è possibile?
Che cosa è successo?
Come posso aiutarmi?
Cosa deve rivivere dentro di me?
Ma c'è solo silenzio.
Non ci sono parole.
Ma sto in ascolto.
Sto in ascolto e ho fiducia
che prima o poi qualcosa deve succedere.
Fino a quando
una mattina mi sveglio
pensando di essere
un piccolo fagiolo secco.
Un piccolo fagiolo secco!
Mi visualizzo allora in quel fagiolo
e mi fido perché viene da me.
Così, nella mia immaginazione,
lo metto nella bambagia,
per farlo crescere
e da quel momento,
decido che io vivo la mia vita
con un fagiolo immaginario in tasca,
e gli dò pure dell'acqua ogni tanto.
I giorni diventano settimane.
La desolazione e il silenzio
si trasformano in curiosità:
ma che cosa sarà mai?
Sarà un fiore, sarà un albero?
Mi accorgo anche che cresce
un senso di responsabilità
verso quel fagiolo secco.
Le settimane diventano mesi.
Il fagiolo secco è sempre lì.
Ma io sto sempre in ascolto,
con il mio fagiolo in tasca.
La curiosità diventa pazienza.
La responsabilità diventa
accettazione della realtà, così com'è.
Almeno, non sono sola:
ho il mio fagiolo in tasca.
Fino a quando, un giorno,
mi accorgo che c'è qualcosa di verde
che spunta da quel fagiolo.
Quel fagiolo oggi è una quercia.
Quello fu un momento di eccellenza.
Avevo avuto
una piccola intuizione positiva.
Un segnale interiore
a cui avevo dato fiducia.
Avevo ascoltato
un mio bisogno,
e mi ero fidata.
E avevo riconosciuto
quello che provavo dentro.
Qual è, allora, il metodo
per vivere questa eccellenza speciale?
È semplice.
Stai in ascolto, fidati
e mettiti in contatto.
Stare in ascolto
significa aprire gli occhi
e accorgersi di quando vivi
una sensazione positiva,
perché questo significa aprire le porte
alle tue risorse profonde,
alle tue qualità.
Perché se ti senti coraggiosa,
è perché hai il coraggio dentro di te.
Se ti senti onesto, paziente,
flessibile o generoso
è perché queste sono qualità
che hai dentro di te
che parlano di te,
e di chi sei veramente.
Ci hai mai pensato?
Le tue sensazioni positive
parlano delle tue qualità.
E invece noi riconosciamo subito
quando ci stiamo per arrabbiare,
quando stiamo diventando nervosi:
siamo inflessibili, impazienti.
Ed è più facile stare
con queste emozioni negative,
e queste sensazioni,
fino a quando sbagliamo,
o danneggiamo la nostra salute.
Ma quante volte in un giorno,
ti accorgi che vivi
una sensazione positiva?
Quando, per esempio, fai qualcosa di bello
per la tua famiglia,
o qualcuno ti sorride,
o prendi la decisione giusta?
O inizi un nuovo progetto,
o ascolti la musica
o tutto quanto sembra andare liscio.
Quante volte
in un giorno ti accorgi?
Qualcuno di voi potrebbe dire,
molto bello quello che stai dicendo -
ma la vita è dura,
e poi è veloce,
e questo non bisogna dimenticarlo.
È vero.
Ma è anche vero che noi siamo nati
con profonde risorse dentro di noi,
e questo non possiamo dimenticarcelo.
E stare in ascolto
significa aprire le porte
e fare entrare in modo decisivo
queste risorse dentro di te.
E significa riconoscere
chi sei veramente,
nella tua essenza.
Quante volte facciamo
delle cose straordinarie
e nemmeno ce ne accorgiamo?
E quante volte diciamo:
non ce la farò mai!
E ci dimentichiamo
delle nostre aspirazioni.
Ma sai che cosa sono le aspirazioni?
Le aspirazioni sono qualità
che bussano alla porta
e chiedono di nascere
e di essere vissute.
Ma ci pensi?
Le tue aspirazioni sono le tue qualità,
che chiedono di nascere
e di essere vissute.
È un po' come quando
vogliamo suonare uno strumento
perché abbiamo la musica dentro.
O come quando
vogliamo sviluppare un progetto
perché abbiamo spirito di iniziativa.
E sai qual è il vantaggio di tutto questo?
Il vantaggio è che più diventi
consapevole delle tue risorse,
e più queste si consolidano
dentro di te,
e più ne scopri di nuove,
e più le puoi usare
quando ne avrai bisogno.
Il secondo passaggio è fidarsi.
Chi di noi oggi può dire
di potersi fidare al 100%?
La fiducia oggi è una cosa difficile.
Non ci fidiamo delle persone,
tanto meno del sistema.
A volte non ci fidiamo
nemmeno di noi stessi
e delle nostre reazioni.
La fiducia di cui parlo è diversa.
È fiducia nelle proprie risorse,
ed è fatta di pazienza e di apertura.
Fidati delle tue risorse.
Perché non importa quanto ci vorrà.
Non importa quanto difficile e dura sarà.
Troverai un modo per andare avanti.
E il tuo corpo e la tua mente
saranno lì, ad aiutarti.
E quando senti una sensazione positiva,
fermati.
Stai con lei. Riconoscila.
E sai qual è la chiave di tutto questo?
La chiave è quella di riconoscere
che ogni momento
è un momento chiave
per stare in ascolto e fidarti.
Perché è in quel momento,
che tu scopri cose
che non credevi di essere.
Il terzo passaggio, e ultimo,
è quello di mettersi in contatto.
Questo è un momento cruciale.
Perché è lì che metti
le frecce nel tuo arco.
Quando senti una sensazione,
un'emozione positiva, sii curioso.
Dai un nome alla tua sensazione
e prova a chiederti,
che cosa sto vivendo adesso?
Esattamente, che cos'è?
È amore, è felicità, è gioia,
è pazienza, è flessibilità?
Che cos'è?
Costruisci la consapevolezza
delle tue risorse.
di quali e quante risorse
hai dentro di te.
Come fai a scalare una montagna,
se non sai quali attrezzi puoi usare?
O quali attrezzi hai a disposizione?
E mi sento di dire anche
un'altra cosa, l'ultima.
Quando senti una sensazione positiva,
prova a vedere dove la senti,
dov'è nel tuo corpo.
Perché le sensazioni
hanno reazioni fisiche.
Esattamente come quando ti arrabbi,
e ti fa male lo stomaco.
O sei depresso,
e hai il respiro al minimo.
O hai delle responsabilità che non vuoi
e ti fa male la schiena
o ti fanno male le spalle,
o hai il mal di testa.
Ma che cosa sai dI te,
e del tuo corpo,
quando sei felice?
Quando sei in pace con te stesso?
Quindi, stai in ascolto, fidati,
e mettiti in contatto.
Il filosofo americano William Darrent,
parafasando Aristotele, scrisse,
Noi siamo ciò che facciamo ripetutamente.
L'eccellenza dunque non è un atto,
ma è un'abitudine.
E allora vivi!
Gusta questa eccellenza speciale
che è dentro di te.
Falla diventare la tua nuova abitudine.
E vedrai che meraviglia.
Grazie.
[Applausi]
Il mio pensiero è:
tutti noi abbiamo un fagiolo,
che vuole crescere.
[Applausi]